thank you
hello everyone welcome to this
interesting video on AWS full course of
2022. in this video we will explore
various important aspects revolving
around AWS and its related Concepts in
depth but before diving deep into its
Concepts we will first cover the basics
and have an introduction to what is AWS
followed by exploring Cloud Computing
Services then we will explore some of
the very important Services provided by
AWS and various categories like compute
storage database and networking
following that we will explore and
understand the complete mechanism and
architecture of some of its very
important features related to Containers
storage and security data AWS ec2 AWS S3
AWS IM
s cloud formation AWS root 53 AWS ECS
AWS Beanstalk
AWS VPC AWS Sage maker AWS cloudfront
AWS Auto scaling and AWS redshift after
which we will have a look at the
comparison between AWS and other Cloud
platforms like Azure and gcp to
understand the individual identities and
how they differ from each other based on
various parameters and we'll also see
how kubernetes are implemented on AWS
and after that we will focus on how we
can adopt AWS in our career and pava
park towards becoming AWS Cloud
practitioner or ews solution architect
after that we will discussions why ews
is a better option to go with
we will then conclude this video by
discussing the essential interview
questions and answer to help every
individual clear an interview with full
confidence by the end of this video I
can assure you that all your AWS career
related queries would have been answered
for this training with me I have a
experienced AWS specialist Sam and Rahul
together we'll walk you through the
different crucial AWS Keynotes
so let's start with an exciting video on
AWS full course of 2022 but before we
begin make sure to subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the Bell icon
and never miss an update from Simply
learn
meet Rob he runs an online shopping
portal the portal started with a modest
number of users but has recently been
seeing a surge in the number of visitors
on Black Friday and other holidays the
portal saw so many visitors that the
servers were unable to handle the
traffic and crashed is there a way to
improve performance without having to
invest in a new server wondered rob a
way to upscale or downscale capacity
depending on the number of users
visiting the website at any given point
well there is Amazon web services one of
the leaders in the cloud computing
Market before we see how AWS can solve
Rob's problem let's have a look at how
AWS reached the position it is at now
AWS was first introduced in 2002 as a
means to provide tools and services to
developers to incorporate features of
amazon.com to their website in 2006 its
first Cloud Services offering was
introduced in 2016 AWS surpassed its 10
billion Revenue Target
and now AWS offers more than 100 cloud
services that span a wide range of
domains thanks to this the AWS cloud
service platform is now used by more
than 45 of the global market now let's
talk about what is AWS AWS or Amazon web
service is a secure cloud computing
platform that provides computing power
database networking content storage and
much more
the platform also works with a PSU go
pricing model which means you only pay
for how much of the service is offered
by AWS you use
some of the other advantages of AWS are
security AWS provides a secure and
durable platform that offers end-to-end
privacy and security
experience you can benefit from the
infrastructure management practices born
from Amazon's years of experience
flexible it allows users to select the
OS language database and other services
easy to use users can host applications
quickly and securely
scalable depending on user requirements
applications can be scaled up or down
AWS provides a wide range of services
across various domains what if Rob
wanted to create an application for his
online portal AWS provides compute
services that can support the app
development process from start to finish
from developing deploying running to
scaling the application up or down based
on the requirements the popular Services
include ec2 AWS Lambda Amazon light cell
and elastic Beanstalk for storing
website data Rob could use AWS storage
services that would enable him to store
access govern and analyze data to ensure
that costs are reduced agility is
improved and Innovation accelerated
popular services within this domain
include Amazon S3 EBS S3 Glacier and
elastic file storage
Rob can also store the user data in a
database with aw Services which he can
then optimize and manage popular
services in this domain include Amazon
RDS dynamodb and redshift if Rob's
businesses took off and he wanted to
separate his Cloud infrastructure or
scale up his work requests and much more
he would be able to do so with the
networking Services provided by AWS some
of the popular networking Services
include Amazon VPC Amazon Route 53 and
elastic load balancing other domains
that AWS provide services in are
analytics blockchain containers machine
learning internet of things and so on
and there you go that's AWS for you in a
nutshell now before we're done let's
have a look at a quiz which of these
services are incorrectly matched one
two
three
four
we'll be pinning the question in the
comments section comment below with your
answer and stand a chance to win an
Amazon voucher several companies around
the world have found great success with
AWS companies like Netflix twitch
LinkedIn Facebook and BBC have taken
advantage of the services offered by AWS
to improve their business efficiency and
thanks to their widespread usage AWS
professionals are in high demand they're
highly paid and earn up to more than one
hundred and twenty seven thousand
dollars per annum once you're AWS
certified you could be one of them too
hello everyone let me introduce myself
as Sam a multi-platform cloud architect
and trainer and I'm so glad and I'm
equally excited to talk and walk you
through the session about what AWS is
and talk to you about some services and
offerings and about how companies get
benefited by migrating their
applications and infra into AWS so
what's AWS let's talk about that now
before that let's talk about how life
was without any cloud provider and in
this case how life was without AWS so
let's why back and picture how things
were back in 2000 which is not so long
ago but a lot of changes a lot of
changes for better had happened since
that time now back in 2000 a request for
a new server is not an happy thing at
all because a lot of money a lot of
validations a lot of planning are
involved in getting a server online or
up and running and even after we finally
got the server it's not all said and
done a lot of optimization that needs to
be done on that server to make it worth
it and get a good return on investment
from that server and even after we have
optimized for a good return on
investment the work is still not done
there will often be a frequent increase
and decrease in the capacity and you
know even news about our website getting
popular and getting more hits It's still
an Bittersweet experience because now I
need to add more servers to the
environment which means that it's going
to cost me even more but thanks to the
present day Cloud technology if the same
situation were to happen today my new
server it's almost ready and it's ready
instantaneously and with the Swift tools
and technologies that Amazon is
providing uh in provisioning my server
instantaneously and adding any type of
workload on top of it and making my
storage and server secure you know
creating a durable storage where data
that I stored in the cloud never gets
lost with all that features Amazon has
got our back so let's talk about what is
AWS there are a lot of definitions for
it but I'm going to put together a
simple and a precise definition as much
as possible now let me iron that out
Cloud still runs on and Hardware all
right and there are certain features in
that infrastructure in that cloud
infrastructure that makes cloud cloud or
that makes AWS a cloud provider now we
get all the services all the
Technologies all the features and all
the benefits that we get in our local
data center like you know security and
compute capacity and databases and in
fact you know we get even more cool
features like content caching in various
global locations around the planet but
again out of all the features the best
part is that I get or we get everything
on a pay as we go model the less I use
the less I pay and the more I use the
less I pay per unit very attractive
isn't it right and that's not all the
applications that we provision in AWS
are very reliable because they run on a
reliable infrastructure and it's very
scalable because it runs on an on-demand
infrastructure and it's very flexible
because of the designs and because of
the design options available for me in
the cloud let's talk about how all this
happened AWS was launched in 2002 after
the Amazon we know as the online retail
store wanted to sell their remaining or
unused infrastructure as a service or as
an offering for customers to buy and use
it from them you know sell
infrastructure as a service the idea
sort of clicked and AWS launched their
first product first product in 2006
that's like four years after the idea
launch and in 2012 they held a big sized
customer even to gather inputs and
concerns from customers and they were
very dedicated in making those requests
happen and that habit is still being
followed it's still being followed as
reinvent by AWS and at 2015 Amazon
announced its Revenue to be 4.6 billion
and in 2015 through 2016 AWS launched
products and services that helped help
migrate customer services into AWS well
their web products even before but this
is when a lot of focus was given on and
developing migrating services and in the
same year that's in 2016 Amazon's
revenue was 10 billion and not but not
the least as we speak Amazon has more
than 100 products and services available
for customers and get benefited from all
right let's talk about the services that
are available in Amazon let's start with
this product called S3 now S3 is a great
tool for internet backup and it's it's
the cheapest storage option in the
object storage category and not only
that the data that we put in S3 is
retrievable from the internet S3 is
really cool and we have other products
like migration and data collection and
data transfer products and here we can
not only collect data seamlessly but
also in a real-time way monitor the data
or analyze the data that's being
received that they're cool products like
AWS data transfers available that helps
achieve that and then we have products
like ec2 elastic compute Cloud that's an
resizable computer where we can anytime
anytime after the size of the computer
based on the need or based on the
forecast then we have SIMPLE
notification Services systems and tools
available in Amazon to update us with
notifications through email or through
SMS now anything anything can be sent
through email or through SMS if you use
that service it could be alarms or it
could be service notifications if you
want stuff like that and then we have
some security tools like KMS key
management system which uses AES 256-bit
encryption to encrypt our data at rest
then we have Lambda as service for which
we pay only for the time in seconds
seconds it takes to execute our code and
we're not paying for the info structure
here it's just the seconds that the
program is going to take to execute the
code of the short program will be paying
in a milliseconds if it's a bit bigger
program we'll be probably paying in 60
seconds or 120 seconds but that's a lot
cheap lot simple and lots cost effective
as against paying for service on an
hourly basis which a lot of other
services are well that's cheap but using
Lambda is a lot cheaper than that and
then we have services like Route 53 at
DNS service in the cloud and now I do
not have to maintain and DNS account
somewhere else and my cloud environment
with AWS I can get both in the same
place all right let me talk to you about
how AWS makes life easier or how
companies got benefited by using AWS as
their it provider for their applications
or for the infrastructure now Unilever
is a company and they had a problem
right and they had a problem and they
picked AWS as a solution to their
problem right now this company was sort
of spread across 190 countries and they
were relying on a lot of digital
marketing for promoting their products
and their existing environment their
legacy local environment proved not to
support their changing I.T demands and
uh they could not standardize their old
environment now they chose to move part
of their applications to AWS because
they were not getting what they wanted
in their local environment and since
then you know rollouts were easy
provisioning new applications became
easy and even producing infrastructure
became easy and they were able to do all
that in push button scaling and needless
to talk about uh backups that are safe
and backups that can be securely
accessed from the cloud as needed now
that company is growing along with AWS
because of their Swift speed in rolling
out deployments and being able to access
secure backups from various places and
gendered reports and in in fact useful
reports out of it that helps their
business now on the same lines let me
also talk to you about Kellogg's and how
they got benefited by using Amazon now
Kellogg's had a different problem it's
one of its kind now their business model
was very dependent on an infra that will
help to analyze data really fast right
because they were running promotions
based on the analyzed data that they get
so they're being able to respond to the
analyzed data as soon as possible was
critical or vital in their environment
and luckily sap running on Hana
environment is what they needed and you
know they picked that service in the
cloud and that sort of solved the
problem now the company does not have to
deal with maintaining their legacy infra
and maintaining their heavy compute
capacity and maintaining their a
database locally all that is now moved
to the cloud or they are using Cloud as
their it service provider and and now
they have a greater and Powerful it
environment that very much complements
their business let me start the session
with this scenario let's imagine how
life would have been without Spotify for
those who are hearing about Spotify for
the first time a Spotify is an online
music service offering and it offers
instant access to over 16 million
licensed songs Spotify now uses AWS
Cloud to store the data and share it
with their customers but prior to AWS
they had some issues imagine using
spotify before AWS let's talk about that
back then users were often getting
errors because Spotify could not keep up
with the increased demand for storage
every new day and that led to users
getting upset and users canceling the
subscription the problem Spotify was
facing at that time was their users were
present globally and were accessing it
from everywhere and they had different
latency in their applications and
Spotify had a demanding situation where
they need to frequently catalog the song
songs released yesterday today and in
the future and this was changing every
new day and the songs coming in rate was
about 20 000 a day and back then they
could not keep up with this requirement
and needless to say they were badly
looking for a way to solve this problem
and that's when they got introduced to
AWS and it was a perfect fit and match
for their problem AWS offered a
dynamically increasing storage and
that's what they needed AWS also offered
tools and techniques like storage life
cycle management and trusted advisor to
properly utilize the resource so we
always get the best out of the resource
used AWS addressed their concerns about
easily being able to scale yes you can
scale the AWS environment very easily
how easily one might ask it's just a few
button clicks and AWS sold spotify's
problem let's talk about how it can help
you with your organization's problem
let's talk about what is AWS first and
then let's bleed into to how AWS became
so successful and the different types of
services that AWS provides and what's
the future of cloud and AWS in specific
let's talk about that and finally we'll
talk about a use case where you will see
how easy it is to create a web
application with AWS all right let's
talk about what is AWS AWS or Amazon web
services is a secure cloud service
platform it is also pay as you go type
billing model where there is no upfront
or Capital cost we'll talk about how
soon the service will be available well
the service will be available in a
matter of seconds with AWS you can also
do identity and access management that
is authenticating and authorizing a user
or a program on the Fly and almost all
the services are available on demand and
most of them are available
instantaneously and as we speak Amazon
offers 100 plus services and this list
is growing every new week now that would
make you wonder how AWS became so
successful of course it's their
customers let's talk about the list of
well-known companies that has their ID
environment in AWS Adobe Adobe uses AWS
to provide multi-terabyte operating
environments for its customers by
integrating its system with AWS Cloud
Adobe can focus on deploying and
operating its own software instead of
trying to you know deploy and manage the
infrastructure Airbnb is another company
it's an Community Marketplace that
allows property owners and travelers to
connect each other for the purpose of
renting unique vacation spaces around
the world and the Airbnb Community users
activities are conducted on the website
and through iPhones and Android
applications Airbnb has a huge
infrastructure in AWS and they're almost
using all the services in AWS and are
getting benefited from it another
example would be Autodesk Autodesk
develops software for engineering
designing and entertainment Industries
using services is like Amazon ideas or
rational database service and Amazon S3
or Amazon simple storage service
Autodesk can focus on deploying or
developing its machine learning tools
instead of spending that time on
managing the infrastructure AOL or
American online uses AWS and using AWS
they have been able to close data
centers and decommission about 14 000
in-house and co-located servers and move
Mission critical workload to the cloud
and extend its Global reach and save
millions of dollars on energy resources
bitdefender is an internet security
software firm and their portfolio of
softwares include antivirus and
anti-spyware products bitdefender uses
ec2 and they are currently running few
hundred instances that handle about 5
terabytes of data and they also use
elastic load balancer to load balance
the connection coming in to those
instances across availability zones and
they provide seamless Global delivery of
servers which because of that the BMW
group it uses AWS for its new connected
Car application that collects sensor
data from BMW 7 Series cars to give
drivers dynamically updated map
information Canon's office Imaging
products division benefits from faster
deployment times lower cost and Global
reach by using AWS to deliver
cloud-based services such as mobile
print the office Imaging products
division uses AWS such as Amazon S3 and
Amazon Route 53 Amazon cloudfront and
Amazon IM for their testing development
and Production Services Comcast it's the
world's largest cable company and the
leading provider of internet service in
the United States Comcast uses AWS in a
hybrid environment out of all the other
Cloud providers Comcast chores AWS for
its flexibility and scalable hybrid
infrastructure Docker is a company
that's helping redefine the way
developers build ship and run
applications the this company focuses on
making use of containers for this
purpose and in AWS the service called
the Amazon ec2 container service is
helping them achieve it the esa or
European Space Agency although much of
esa's work is done by satellites some of
the programs data storage and Computing
infrastructure is built on Amazon web
services Esa chose AWS because of its
economical pay as you go system as well
as its quick startup time the Guardian
newspaper uses AWS and it uses a wide
range of AWS services including Amazon
Kinesis Amazon redshift that power and
analytic dashboard which editors use to
see how stories are trending in real
time Financial Times FD is one of the
world's largest leading business news
organization and they used Amazon
redshift to perform their analysis A
Funny Thing Happened Amazon Redshirt
performed so quickly that some analysis
thought it was malfunctioning they were
used to running link queries overnight
and they found that the results were
indeed correct just as much faster by
using Amazon redshift FD is supporting
the same business functions with costs
that are 80 percentage lower than what
was before general electric GE is at the
moment as we speak migrating more than
9000 workloads including 300 desperate
Erp systems to AWS while reducing its
data center footprint from 34 to 4 over
the next three years similarly Howard
Medical School HTC IMDb McDonald's NASA
Kellogg's and lot more are using the
services Amazon provides and are getting
benefited from it and this huge success
and customer portfolio is just the tip
of the iceberg and if we think why so
many adapt AWS and if we let AWS answer
that question this is what AWS would say
people are adapting AWS because of the
security and durability of the data and
end-to-end privacy and encryption of the
data and storage it experience we can
also rely on AWS way of doing things by
using the AWS tools and techniques and
suggested best practices built upon the
years of experience it has gained
flexibility there is a greater
flexibility in AWS that allows us to
select the OS language and database easy
to use swiftness in deploying we can
host our applications quickly in AWS be
it a new application or migrating an
existing application into AWS
scalability the application can be
easily scaled up or scaled down
depending on the user requirement cost
saving we only pay for the compute power
storage and other resources you use and
that too without any long-term
commitments now let's talk about the
different types of services that AWS
provides the services that we talk about
fall in any of the following categories
you see like you know compute storage
database Security customer engagement
desktop and streaming machine learning
developers tools stuff like that and if
you do not see the servers that you look
looking for it's probably is because AWS
is creating it as we speak now let's
look at some of them that are very
commonly used within compute Services we
have Amazon ec2 Amazon elastic Beanstalk
Amazon light sale and Amazon Lambda
Amazon ec2 provides compute capacity in
the cloud now this capacity is secure
and it is resizable based on the user's
requirement now look at this the
requirement for the web traffic keeps
changing and behind the scenes in the
cloud ec2 can expand its environment to
three instances and during no load it
can shrink its environment to just one
resource elastic Beanstalk it helps us
to scale and deploy web applications and
it's made with a number of programming
languages elastic Beanstalk is also an
easy to use service for deploying and
scaling web applications and services
deployed a bit in java.net PHP node.js
python Ruby Docker and lot other
familiar services such as Apache
passenger and IIs we can simply upload
our code an elastic Beanstalk
automatically handles the deployment
from capacity provisioning to load
balancing to Auto scaling to application
Health monitoring and Amazon light sale
is a virtual private server which is
easy to launch and easy to manage Amazon
light cell is the easiest way to get
started with AWS for developers who just
need a virtual private server light cell
includes everything you need to launch
your project quickly on a virtual
machine like SSD based storage a virtual
machine tools for data transfer DNS
management and a static IP and that too
for a very low and predictable price AWS
Lambda has taken Cloud Computing
Services to a whole new level it allows
us to pay only for the compute time no
need for provisioning and managing
servers an AWS Lambda is a compute
service that lets us run code without
provisioning or managing service Lambda
executes your code only when needed and
scales automatically from few requests
per day to thousands per second you pay
only for the compute time you consume
there is no charge when your core is not
running let's look at some storage
services that Amazon provides like
Amazon S3 Amazon Glacier Amazon abs and
Amazon elastic file system Amazon S3 is
an object storage that can store and
retrieve data from anywhere websites
mobile apps iot sensors and so on can
easily use Amazon S3 to store and
retrieve data it's an object storage
built to store and to drive any amount
of data from anywhere with its features
like flexibility in managing data and
the durability it provides and the
security that it provides Amazon simple
storage service or S3 is a storage for
the internet and Glacier Glacier is a
cloud storage service that's used for
archiving data and long-term backups and
this Glacier is an secure durable and
extremely low cost cloud storage service
for data archiving and long-term backups
Amazon EVS Amazon elastic blog store
provides Block store volumes for the
instances of ec2 and this elastic Block
store is highly available and a reliable
storage volume that can be attached to
any running instance that is in the same
availability Zone ABS volumes that are
attached to the ec2 instances are
exposed as storage volumes that persist
and independently from the lifetime of
the instance an Amazon elastic file
system or EFS provides an elastic file
storage which can be used with AWS cloud
service and resources that are on
premises and Amazon elastic file system
it's an simple it's scalable it's an
elastic file storage for use with Amazon
cloud services and for on-premises
resources it's easy to use and offers a
simple interface that allows you to
create and configure file systems
quickly and easily Amazon file system is
built to elastically scale on demand
without disturbing the application
growing and shrinking automatically as
you add and remove files to your
application have the storage they need
and when they need it now let's talk
about databases the two major database
flavors are Amazon RDS and Amazon
redshift Amazon RDS it really eases the
process involved in setting up operating
and scaling a rational database in the
cloud Amazon RDS provides cost efficient
and resizable capacity while automating
time consuming administrative tasks such
as Hardware provisioning database setup
patching and backups it sort of frees us
from managing the hardware and sort of
helps us to focus on the application
it's also cost effective and resizable
and it's also optimized for memory
performance and input and output
operations not only that it also
automates most of the services like
taking backups you know monitoring stuff
like that it automates most of those
Services Amazon redshift Amazon redshift
is a data warehousing service that
enables users to analyze the data using
SQL and other business intelligent tools
Amazon redshift is an fast and fully
managed data warehouse that makes it
simple and cost effective analyze all
your data using standard SQL and your
existing business intelligence in tools
it also allows you to run complex
analytic queries against petabyte or
structured data using sophisticated
query optimizations and most of the
results they generally come back in
seconds all right let's quickly talk
about some more services that AWS offers
there are a lot more services that AWS
provides but are we going to look at
some more services that are widely used
AWS application Discovery Services help
Enterprise customers plan migration
projects by gathering information about
their on-premises data centers in a
planning a data center migration can
involve thousands of workloads they are
often deeply interdependent server
utilization data and dependency mapping
are important early first step in
migration process and this AWS
application Discovery service collects
and presents configuration usage and
behavior data from your servers to help
you better understand your workloads
Route 53 it's a network and content
delivery service it's an highly
available and scalable Cloud domain name
system or DNS service and Amazon on
Route 53 is fully compliant with IPv6 as
well elastic load balancing it's also a
network and content delivery service
elastic load balancing automatically
distributes incoming application traffic
across multiple targets such as Amazon
ec2 instance containers and IP addresses
it can handle the varying load of your
application traffic in a single
available zones and also across
availability zones AWS Auto scaling it
monitors your application and
automatically adjusts the capacity to
maintain steady and predictable
performance at a lowest possible cost
using AWS Auto scaling it's easy to set
up application scaling for multiple
resources across multiple services in
minutes Auto scaling can be applied to
web services and also for DB Services
AWS identity and access management it
enables you to manage access to AWS
services and resources securely using IM
you can create and manage AWS users and
groups and use permissions to allow and
deny their access to AWS resources and
moreover it's a free service us now
let's talk about the future of AWS well
let me tell you something cloud is here
to stay here's what in store for AWS in
the future as years pass by we're gonna
have a variety of cloud applications
born like iot artificial intelligence
business intelligence serverless
Computing and so on cloud will also
expand into other markets like
healthcare banking space automated cars
and so on as I was mentioning some time
back lot or greater Focus will be given
to artificial intelligence and
eventually because of the flexibility
and advantage that cloud provides we're
going to see a lot of companies moving
into the cloud all right let's now talk
about how easy it is to deploy an web
application in the cloud so the scenario
here is that our users like a product
and we need to have a mechanism to
receive input from them about their
likes and dislikes and you know give
them the appropriate product as per
their need alright though the setup and
the environment it sort of looks
complicated we don't have to worry
because AWS has tools and Technologies
which can help us to achieve it now
we're going to use services like Route
53 services like Cloud watch ec2 S3 and
lot more and all these put together are
going to give an application that's
fully functionable and an application
that's going to receive the information
like using the services like Route 53
cloudwatch ec2 and S3 we're going to
create an application and that's going
to meet our need so back to our original
requirement all I want is to deploy a
web application for a product that keeps
our users updated about the happenings
and the newcomings in the market and to
fulfill this requirement here is all the
services we would need ec2 here is used
for provisioning the computational power
needed for this application and ec2 has
a vast variety of family and types that
we can pick from for the types of
workloads and also for the intents of
the workloads we're also going to use S3
for storage and S3 provides any
additional storage requirement for for
the resources or any additional storage
requirement for the web applications and
we are also going to use cloudwatch for
monitoring the environment and
cloudwatch monitors the application and
the environment and it provides trigger
for scaling in and scaling out the
infrastructure and we're also going to
use Route 53 for DNS and Route 53 helps
us to register the domain name for our
web application and with all the tools
and Technologies together all of them
put together we're going to make an
application a perfect application that
caters our need all right so I'm going
to use elastic Beanstalk for this
project and the name of the application
is going to be as you see GSG sign up
and the environment name is GSG signup
environment one let me also pick a name
let me see if this name is available yes
that's available that's the domain name
so let me pick that and the application
that I have is going to run on node.js
so let me pick that platform and launch
now as you see elastic Beanstalk this is
going to launch an instance it's going
to launch the monitoring setup or the
monitoring environment it's going to
create a load balancer as well and it's
going to take care of all the security
features needed for this application
all right look at that I was able to go
to that URL which is what we gave and
it's now having an default page shown up
meaning all the dependencies for the
software is installed and it's just
waiting for me to upload the code or in
specific the page required so let's do
that
let me upload the code I already have
the code saved here
so that's my code
and that's going to take some time all
right it has done its thing and now if I
go to the same URL look at that I'm
being thrown an advertisement page all
right so if I sign up with my name email
and stuff like that you know it's going
to receive the information and it's
going to send an email to the owner
saying that somebody had subscribed to
your service that's the default feature
of this app look at that email to the
owner saying that somebody had
subscribed to your app and this is their
email address stuff like that not only
that it's also going to create an entry
in the database and dynamodb is the
service that this application uses to
store data there's my dynamodb and if I
go to tables all right and go to items
I'm going to see that a user with name
Samuel and email address so and so has
said ok or has shown interest in the
preview of my site or product so this is
where this is how I collect those
information right and some more things
about the infrastructure itself is it is
running behind load balancer look at
that it had created a load balancer it
had also created an auto scaling group
now that's the feature of elastic load
balancer that we have chosen it has
created an auto scaling group and now
let's put this URL you see this it's
it's not a fancy URL all right it's an
Amazon given URL a dynamic URL so let's
put this URL behind our DNS let's do
that
so go to Services go to Route 53
go to hosted Zone and there we can find
the DNS name right so that's a DNS name
all right
all right let's create an entry
and map that URL to our load balancer
right
and create now technically if I go to
this URL it should take me to that
application all right look at that I
went to my custom URL and now that's
pointed to my application previously my
application was having a random URL and
now it's having a custom URL choose from
over 300 in-demand skills and get access
to 1000 plus hours of video content for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
cloud services are available to satisfy
almost any ID requirement
although Cloud Computing Services vary
greatly they all have some basic
qualities and benefits in common
and they can be classified into a few
basic cloud service kinds hello everyone
I'm shamli and I welcome you all to this
new video of Simply learn on Cloud
Computing Services
let me give you an overview of the
concepts you are going to go through in
this video
first we will go through what is cloud
computing
then we will have an introduction to
Cloud Computing Services
followed by the types of Cloud Computing
Services
and at the end we will look into the
features and benefits of Cloud Computing
Services
so let's not waste any more time and get
started with the video
so what is cloud computing
cloud computing is the distribution of
Cloud Computing Services by the internet
including servers storage databases
networking software analytics
intelligence to provide faster
Innovation more flexible resources and
economies of scale
so usually only pay for the cloud
services you use which helps you cut
cost run your infrastructure more
efficiently and scale as your business
grows
now that we know what cloud computing is
let's proceed with understanding Cloud
Computing Services
Cloud Computing Services provide users
with a variety of capabilities including
email storage backup data retrieval app
creation testing data analysis audio
video streaming software on demand
regardless of the time of service
although cloud computing is still a
relatively new technology it is now
being used by a wide range of
organizations including large
Enterprises small businesses non-profit
government agencies and even individual
consumers
so not all clouds are created equal and
not every sort of cloud computing is
appropriate for every situation a
variety of models varieties and services
have evolved to assist you find the best
option for your needs
to begin one must decide on the type of
cloud deployment or cloud computing
architecture
that will be used to implement your
cloud services
cloud services can be deployed in three
different ways public Cloud private
cloud or hybrid cloud
now let's dive down deeper into Cloud
Computing Services and explore its time
in more detail
cloud computing unlike a microprocessor
is not a single piece of technology
rather it's a system made up of three
services
infrastructure as a service
platform as a service
and software as a service
so let's have a better understanding of
each
starting with infrastructure as a
service
so what is infrastructure as a service
it is a type of cloud computing that
uses the internet to provide virtualized
Computing resources
the cloud provider controls it
infrastructures such as storage server
and networking resources and also offers
them to subscribe companies via virtual
machines accessible over the internet in
IAS model
for businesses it can provide numerous
advantages including the ability to make
tasks faster easier more flexible and
less expensive
now let's have a look at the working of
iaas
uses connect to resources and services
across a wide area network such as the
internet and then use the cloud provider
services to complete the applications
tag
the user can for example log into the
infrastructure as a service platform to
build virtual machines install operating
systems in each VM deploy middleware
such as databases create storage buckets
for workloads and backups and install
the Enterprise workload onto that
virtual machine
customers can then track cost monitor
performance balance Network traffic
solve application difficulties and
manage Disaster Recovery using the
provider service
so moving ahead let's go through its
advantages and disadvantages
advantages
organizations select infrastructure as a
service because operating a workload
without having to buy manage and support
the underlying infrastructure is
frequently easier faster and more cost
effective a company can rent or lease
infrastructure from another company
using infrastructure as a service
for workloads that are transitory
experimental or change abruptly
it is an effective cloud service
Paradigm for example if a company is
creating a new software product hiring
an ieas provider
to host and test the application may be
more cost effective
once the new software has been
thoroughly tested and refined the
company can move it away from the
iaas environment
and into a more traditional in-house
deployment
if the expenses of a long-term
commitment are lower the organization
could commit the piece of software to a
long term
iaas deployment
now disadvantages
billing can be a challenge for some
firms despite its flexible payers you go
model Cloud invoicing is quite detailed
and it is broken down to reflect
specific service usage
when evaluating the invoices for each
resource and service involved in
application deployment uses frequently
experienced sticker shock or discover
expenses that are greater than expected
another issue it face is lack of insight
because its providers own the
infrastructure the configuration and
performance of that infrastructure are
rarely transparent to its con consumers
users may find it more difficult to
operate and monitor systems due to the
lack of transparency
users infrastructure as a service are
also concerned about service
availability and reliability
the supplier has a big influence on the
workloads availability and performance
the workloads of users will be impacted
if a provider has Network constraint or
any other type of internal or external
outage
furthermore because it is a multi-teen
in design the problem of noisy neighbors
might have an adverse effect on user's
workloads
so now these are the top infrastructure
as a service providers
line node is a privately held Cloud
hosting firm based in the United States
that offers virtual private servers
host wins web hosting Cloud hosting and
dedicated server options are all
available from host wins
Microsoft Azure is a cloud computing
service operated by Microsoft for
application
management via Microsoft managed data
centers
digitalocean offers developers cloud
service
that make it easy to deploy and grow
programs that run on several machines at
the same time
Alibaba cloud is a cloud computing firm
that serves online businesses as well as
alibaba's own e-commerce ecosystem
so the second service is platform as a
service
what is platform as a service
platform is a service products which are
geared towards software development
teams include Computing and storage
infrastructure as well as development
platform layer that includes web servers
database Management systems and software
development kits for multiple
programming languages
working of platform as a service
for software development
it does not replace an organization's
complete I.T infrastructure
it's made possible by the hosted
infrastructure of a cloud service
provider
a web browser is the most common way for
users to access the offerings
platform is a service such as
application hosting and Java development
can be supplied by a public private or
hybrid clouds
so now let's look into the advantages
and disadvantages
advantages
the main advantage of platform as a
service for users is its Simplicity and
convenience
much of the infrastructure and other ID
services will be provided by the
platform as a service provider
Rich users can access from anywhere via
a web browser
the flexibility to pay on a per use
basis allows businesses to forego the
capital costs associated with
on-premises gear and software
many platform as a service solutions are
aimed towards software developers these
platform provider computation and
storage infrastructures as well as text
editing version management compilation
and testing capabilities to assist
developers in swiftly and efficiently
developing new software
coming to the disadvantages platform as
a service on the other hand can cause
issues
with service availability and resilience
customers may suffer as a result of of a
service outage or other infrastructure
Interruption which might result in
costly productivity losses
IT Supplies on the other hand will
typically deliver reasonably high up
times
another widespread problem is when the
lock-in which occurs when users are
unable to Simply transition many of
their services and data from one
platform as a service solution to
another
when choosing a provider users must
consider the business risk of service
outages and vendor lock-in
internal changes to a platform as a
service product could also be a problem
the impact on users might be tough and
receptive
if a platform as a service provider
seizes supporting a programming language
or chooses to use a different set of
development tools
so let's have a look at the top platform
as a service provider
IBM cloud computing refers to a set of
Cloud Computing Services for businesses
provided by IBM a technology corporation
red hat is a collection of tightly
integrated Red Hat Technologies for
building Cloud infrastructure and
developing Cloud native apps on-premises
elastic Beanstalk AWS elastic Beanstalk
is an Amazon web services application
deployment orchestration solution
Salesforce offers CRM Services as well
as Enterprise applications for customer
service marketing automation analytics
and application development
and software AG cloud is an open and
independent Cloud platform that serves
as your One-Stop shop for all software
AG has to offer in the cloud
now coming to the next service which is
software as a service
so what is software as a service
customer relationship management or CRM
marketing Automation and business
analytics are just a few of the
application Level services offered by
software as a service companies
so how does it work
the provider gives consumers network
based access to a single copy of an
application that the provider design
expressly for software as a service
distribution
in the software on-demand model
the source code for the program is the
same for all clients and new features of
functionalities are rolled out to all
the users at the same time
since the data of each model's customer
may be stored locally in the cloud or
both locally in the cloud depending on
the service level agreement
coming to its advantages
customer subscribe to a software as a
service solution rather than buying and
installing software or additional gear
to support it many firms can now budget
more effectively and predictably by
converting cost to recurrent operating
expenses you can also cancel software as
a service subscriptions at any time to
avoid incurring recurring fees
its systems are frequently customizable
and can be connected with other
corporate applications particularly when
using software for the same vendor
vertical scalability is a feature of
cloud services like software as a
service which allows clients to access
more or fewer services or features on
demand
disadvantages of software as a service
when providers indoor
service delays impose undesirable
modifications to service offerings or
suffer a security breach all of these
things can have a significant impact on
customers
ability to use the software as a service
offering
customers should be aware of their
software as a service providers SLA and
ensure that it is followed
if the provider adopts a new version of
an application it will roll it out to
all of its clients whether or not they
want it
this may need the organization
allocating additional training time and
resources
switching vendors can be tough as it is
with any cloud service provider
customers must migrate massive volumes
of data when switching vendors
furthermore some vendors use
Technologies and data types which can
make transparent client data between
Cloud providers even more difficult
so coming to the top companies that
provide software as a service
Adobe is a collection of adobe
incorporation programs and services that
provide user with access to software for
graphic design video editing web
development and photography as well as a
set of mobile apps and certain optional
cloud services
sap is a platform as a service designed
by sapse for developing new application
and enhancing
existing ones in a secure cloud
computing environment managed by sap
Google Cloud Google Cloud platform is a
set of Cloud Computing Services provided
by Google that run on the same
infrastructure as Google's internal
products such as Google search Gmail
drive and YouTube
freshworks Cloud platform allows users
to manage their identities and access
across all of their freshworks products
and adulation Advanced features such as
a 99.9 uptime SLE unlimited storage and
premium support provide themes the
confidence to scale reliably
now that we have all the in-depth
information about different types of
Cloud Computing Services let's move
ahead and explore its benefits and
features which makes it so popular and
convenient
first the supplier host and maintains
the site in their own facility the cloud
hosting provider acquires host and
maintains the necessary hardware and
software
users avoid the construction
expenditures and maintenance problem
that would be incurred if the service
was established on premise
second set service using a web-based
interface through a web interface
serviced users can initiate certain
service functions as well as increase or
reduce their service consumption level
with little or no intervention from the
service provider
third is you must pay to utilize the
facility
users of the service only pay for the
services they use when compared to the
typical method of building on-site it
capacities
targeted for the highest usage
situations and then having that capacity
to go unused for the most of the time
this can result in significant cost
savings
and the fourth one is scalability that
comes close to being infinite cloud
computing service providers usually have
the instruction infrastructure in place
to deliver their services at a large
scale that means that cloud service
consumers can readily accommodate
business expansion or periodic surges in
service usage
well this is all about Cloud Computing
Services hello everybody Welcome to
simplylearn's AWS S3 tutorial for
beginners my name is Kent and today I'm
going to be covering these following
points I'm going to be covering what is
cloud computing I'm going to be
showcasing what AWS is in terms of cloud
computing and I'm also going to be
covering the core fundamental service of
the simple storage service which is a
object storage service we're going to be
covering the benefits of the simple
storage service better known as S3 what
objects and buckets are and we're going
to be seeing how things are working in
the background and implementing that in
terms of lab assisted demonstrations in
order for you to see what those features
of s3r and then we'll perform a wrap up
of the material we've done in a
conclusion
so let's get started what is cloud
computing
so here is a definition of cloud
computing but I'm going to paraphrase it
cloud computing is nothing more than you
gaining access to infrastructure
through web services with a
pay-as-you-go model now this is a very
very different model than where
traditionally
involved in on a on-prem
data center so when I mean on-prem I'm
saying on premise okay so you'll hear
that a lot on-prem now when we are on
on-premise data center we have to
provision lots of infrastructure even
before we get started with
deploying any type of application
whether it be a mobile application a web
application etc etc
so every application needs some sort of
underlying infrastructure whether that
be bare bone servers databases they're
obviously going to be needing some types
of storage
etc etc so all this
is something that we have to kind of
fight against in order just to get
started with deploying our application
so this takes usually traditionally
depending on the size of the company
about three months to set up
so what if we could Leverage
all this infrastructure
as a service and just through some API
call web services is all about deploy
any type of application that we want to
on top of that stack and also take
advantage of any storage that we may
want we may want object level storage
which is what we're going to cover we
may want an elastic file system right so
there are different types of storages
that were eventually going to look at as
you go down your learning path with
simply learn so cloud computing is
really about provisioning of all these
kinds of services but not only at the
infrastructure level we're going to see
how we could move up the stack and get
entire platforms as a service or even
softwares as a service so what is AWS
while AWS is really a cloud computing
platform that will offer us many many
services through these API calls some
are again just bare infrastructure like
a service other can be a service as a
software for example email so here we
have an example
of the public data storage this is S3
the simple storage service icon that
you're going to see over and over again
this is a representation of an actual
bucket in S3 so this will become more
clear as we continue the slide deck and
actually reinforce this with some
Hands-On lab but as you can imagine you
may want to provision a
private
software-defined Network in the cloud
and so we can do that in AWS we can
provide load balancing we could provide
scalability in terms of Auto scaling
groups that will respond to increased
demand as your application let's say
um becomes more popular you want that
infrastructure to procurring all the
hardware that you need beforehand and
the budget being approved before even
getting that Hardware in through your
door right and then you have to
configure it so there's that complexity
Factor
whereas if you're doing this through AWS
you can within minutes
just provision all of that very quickly
so you're also not paying for every
brings and configure them and scale them
etc etc so if we remove that element and
have AWS handle that we can concentrate
on our business which is our application
and improving that application
and responding more to our clients
request will be more agile more flexible
so all of this leads to these points
that we see here on this slide much
easier to use much easier to get our
application to Market we're actually
going to be leveraging the physical
security that AWS implements for us they
have data centers all over the world
that we're going to plug into and that
physical security is already implemented
for us there are varying levels of
security that we're going to get into
through our AWS Journey but right off
the bat you know that you have physical
security of course we're going to be
talking about storage in this
demonstration or slide deck over here
but the nice thing is is we only pay for
what we use so that's that variable
expense that I was talking about that
we've traded for Capital expense we can
easily set up databases we can easily
automate our backups and have those
backups stored
in the cloud through that S3 storage
that we're going to get into okay so
lots of benefits of going through AWS
here
and it's also comprehensive and simple
to use
comprehensive meaning that there are
hundreds and hundreds of services
it's going to be actually quite time
consuming for you to just know what each
service does in general but you'll get
there through your journey it's all
about sticking with it and learning
something new every day which is what
simple learn is all about
um over here we have infrastructure as a
service platform as a service and
software as a service so these are three
different types of distinctions we have
in the cloud industry to basically
cover what's going on here on the right
hand side so on premise you're
traditionally involved in everything
from networking which is you for example
buying the switches the routers the
cabling everything all the way up the
stack to deploying your application and
you see everything in between there okay
so this is a very time consuming job not
only that but it costs a lot of money
because you have to buy all these
machines up front and you have to have
the individuals with the right knowledge
to maintain all of this stack all right
so different individuals and different
teams maintaining this whole on-premise
data center you may also have different
data centers deployed globally so you
can imagine the cost overhead of this
so everything in green is basically
you're managing it
now we can offset that and ask AWS to
handle part of this stack over here so
on this second Point column over here we
see infrastructure as a service which
basically says AWS I want you to handle
all the networking my software-defined
network I want you to handle my storage
elasticity I want you to handle my
compute power my virtual machines I want
you to handle even
uh administrating those machines at a
physical layer as well and I want you to
physically secure them so this will
allow you more time to focus on all the
green up here
of course we can move up the stack and
say I even want AWS to take on more
responsibility
and that would be more of a platform as
a service where AWS would also install
and maintain the operating system for
you so you can imagine things like new
versions of operating systems security
patches maintenance patches all of the
like and any middleware or run time that
you have on top of that think of
something like the Java a virtual
machine perhaps that needs to be updated
now you wouldn't be
responsible for maintaining all of
what's in Orange over here you would
only be responsible for deploying your
application and making sure that your
data is saved and secured right so again
platform as a service is a more
hands-off approach so think of it as you
wanted to set up a CI CD deployment
environment
for your development team and you want
it to be very
involved in just handling your
application code and making sure that it
was properly
compiled built tested and deployed right
well this could be implemented as a
platform as a service or you could take
your code as a zip file and give it to
aws's
uh service called Beanstalk which would
automatically deploy your code and make
sure that it's highly available scalable
and fault tolerant across all of the
orange stack over here right so more of
a hands-off approach of course we can go
all the way up to stock and tell AWS to
take care of everything for us and just
ask for a service much like a utility
like electricity or water we might want
to say we just want an email software
service and we're not really concerned
about how the underlying operating
system or servers or network are
configured for that we just want to use
the software as a service we don't want
to administrate anything else we just
want to be sort of like an end user to
it so AWS will manage everything
underneath the hood so there are varying
types of services you pick and choose
whichever one makes more sense for you
and your team
so what is S3 S3 stands for simple
storage service and it is an object
storage service in Amazon what this
means is that it doesn't matter what
kind of file you upload to S3 it will be
treated as an abstraction meaning an
object so you can upload a PDF file you
can upload a JPEG file you can upload a
database backup it doesn't really matter
all that is abstracted Away by the use
of storing it within an object we're
going to talk more about what composes
an object but by doing so what happens
is is S3 allows us to have
industry leading scalability so it
doesn't matter if you're going to make a
request for that database backup let's
say that object
five times or ten thousand times that
request that demand will scale the
underlying infrastructure that is
implemented behind the scenes is handled
for you so in a sense it's kind of like
a serverless service a storage service
where you're not implicated in handling
anything underneath the covers you're
just uploading your objects and
accessing them later on in terms of data
availability very powerful as well
because it takes those objects and will
replicate them across at least three
availability zones of course these
availability zones have one or more data
centers attached to them so you have
lots and lots of copies of your objects
distributed globally
or at least at a regional in a regional
area you can do this as well globally if
you enable global replication
and you will see that your level of your
availability will Skyrocket and you're
just not going to worry about losing an
S3 object
data security well we can encrypt our
data at rest our objects at rest we can
encrypt it in transit we can also come
up with security policies at the Bucket
Level which we're going to talk about
when a bucket is very very very soon
these are going to be implemented
through what's called I am policies and
you're going to be able to control who
or what has access to your objects
and of course because everything is
handled underneath the covers all the
servers all the storage nodes are Cloud
optimized for the best possible
performance
so let's continue on our journey on what
is S3 we're going to take a look at what
is a bucket and what is an object as you
can see here you have inside this bucket
which is a logical container for an
unlimited amount of objects you could
have objects of different shapes and
sizes like I said you could have
pictures database backups Etc so this is
what's being represented here by
different shapes and you can think of a
bucket really as almost like a folder
where objects or files are placed within
them
so there are many ways for us to place
objects within a bucket we can do this
through the AWS console which I'll be
showing you very shortly we can do this
via the command line interface or we can
do this to a software development kit at
the end of the day all those three
options go through an API right so it's
all about picking the right method that
is best suited for whatever kind of end
user or application that needs access to
these buckets and to these objects now
once you've got the data or objects
within this bucket
you can control pretty much how the data
is accessed how it's stored whether you
want it to be encrypted and how it's
even managed so you can have
organizations that have specific
compliance needs for example any objects
that are placed in or perhaps in PDFs
are not to be modified or not to be
touched for 90 days let's say we can
imply object locks if we want to we can
imply security guards we can also for
example record all API actions
that try to access to list to delete any
kind of API operations on those objects
at the Bucket Level or on the object
level we can record if that is some sort
of organizational compliance need for
auditing or for whatever internal
auditing reasoning that you may have
so continuing on here you can see that
there are many organizations that use S3
one in point is Amazon itself S3 is so
popular and so durable that Amazon
internally uses it to store its own data
you're guaranteed you know almost that
you're not going to lose any object in
there because it has what we call 11 9's
durability now 11 9's durability is
really an extreme amount of durability
where it's mathematically
almost impossible for you to lose an
object once you place it in S3 you're in
fact more liable to get hit by a
meteorite than you are to lose an object
in S3 statistically speaking which is a
pretty incredible statistic but it's but
it's true
so if we continue here with the benefits
of S3 some of these have already
described but let's talk about the full
picture here we see the performance
scalability availability and durability
of S3 are really uh you know first class
in the industry again durability we were
talking about that 11 9 so what that
really means is
99.99999 in total if you count all the
nines that's 11 of those nine so
um most durable in the industry by far
and again because everything is handled
underneath the covers it's a serverless
service they ensure the scalability and
availability and the performance of
um the inner workings of that object
level storage now cost is of course
always important and S3 really shows up
here with first class support again for
cost it's got very very low cost we can
have object level storage for let's say
a terabyte of object level storage for
as little as a dollar
a month so again it will depend on the
kind of storage class we're going to
have a discussion on different types of
storage classes that we might want to
transition or move over our objects for
one storage class to the next depending
on how frequently accessed that data is
as you know data over time seems to get
less and less accessed as you know your
needs shift from
one place to another we're going to talk
about that coming up very soon so we're
going to want to really focus on that to
reduce our end of the month costs for
storage with S3 of course security is
always at the Forefront and we want to
make sure that we either simply secure
by encrypting everything right off the
bat either at rest in transit or we want
to put an object lock or just maintain
security at the Bucket Level maintaining
let's say who or what has access to that
data because by default no one has
access to the data unless we open up the
door and also we want to make sure that
we don't give public access to our
bucket for obvious reasons of
um giving away important information by
mistake so AWS makes it extremely
difficult for you to accidentally do
this and I'm going to show this in a
demonstration lab coming up very soon
and we can also query in place which is
very interesting so you can imagine you
putting let's say
a file that's in CSV format or a Json
format or parquet format some sort of
structured format or semi-structured
format in S3 and you could actually use
SQL queries on the spot to filter that
data in place at the Bucket Level you
could also have other services that may
want to extract some business
intelligence from that data in your S3
bucket directly as well so some other
more advanced querying operations can
take place at the S3 level so this you
will learn during your journey with
simply learn as you're covering all the
AWS technology stacks
and here the most widely used storage
cloud service in the industry because of
all the points that we just covered it
really is the number one storage or
object level storage solution in the
industry
let's now take a look at objects and
buckets in S3 so the objects are really
the fundamental entities that are stored
in S3 or the lowest common denominator
which means that we're not really
interested in what kind of data is
within the object at the layer of S3
because S3 doesn't have direct access to
the data within an object like I said
before it's an abstraction of the data
so we don't know if it's a cat's picture
if it's a backup of your database it's
just treated as a fundamental entity aka
the object now every object is
associated with metadata so data about
itself things like what's the name of
the object what's the size the time and
date that the object was uploaded things
of that nature are categorized
as metadata so S3 does have direct
access to that now the data within that
object of course is accessible by other
services so it's not that once you've
uploaded it you've totally lost the data
and it's only can be treated as an
object it's just that at this layer
it's simply just assigned metadata and a
version ID a unique version ID and if
you re-upload the exact same object a
second or third time to S3 it will have
its own version ID number so a new
unique version ID number will be
generated
so really what buckets are are there
logical containers to store those
objects so of course at an extremely
high level a bucket would be like your
root file system if you want to think
about it like that but that doesn't mean
you can't go into this bucket and create
separate folders now when you create
separate folders in a bucket because you
might want to logically organize all
your objects
you might be fooled by the fact that you
think this is a hierarchical storage
system when in fact it is not and I'll
talk about that in a second so you
cannot store an object without first
storing it into a bucket so of course
the first step would be for us to create
a bucket and then upload objects within
that bucket so an object connect can
cannot exist without its container or
its bucket
so there's no windows explore view like
we're used to in an operating system
because this is not a hierarchical view
no matter if you create folders within
folders within folders in fact S3's
internal architecture is a flat
hierarchy
what we do instead is we assign prefixes
which are treated as folders in order to
logically organize our objects within
our buckets and I'm going to Showcase a
prefix in one of the demonstrations
coming up very soon
so when you create or when you're
working with S3 first of all you're
working at a regional level you're gonna
have to pick a region for example you
might pick us East one region or USC's
two region and the bucket that you're
going to be creating will be replicated
across several availability zones but
within that region
also that data those objects can be
accessed globally because S3 uses the
HTTP protocol HTTP protocol is very
permissive everybody knows how to
administrate it and work with it so we
just need to give access to that object
in terms of a permission policy
and give it the proper
URL or give whoever needs access to the
proper URL and they can access that via
HTTP globally so first when you're
creating a bucket you have to select the
region and the object will live within
that region but that doesn't mean that
it still can't be accessed globally
so let's now take a minute go over to
the AWS console and actually let me
showcase how to create
objects and buckets
so for our first lab we're going to be
going and creating an S3 bucket and
uploading an object to it so we first
have to log into the AWS console which
we have up here in the address bar
let's click on either create free
account if it's your very first time or
as in is in my case already have an
account and we're going to sign in here
you're gonna have to pass in your IM
username password and your account ID of
course
once you've logged in you can search for
the simple storage service S3 either by
coming up here in the search box and
typing S3 and you'll find it there
that's probably the easiest way or if
you want you can take a look at all the
services and it'll be under storage over
here the first one okay so pick whatever
method you see best for yourself
once we're here we want to create
our first bucket
now I've already have a couple of
buckets here so we're going to go on and
create a new bucket the very first thing
is you have to specify a bucket name now
this bucket name has to be globally
unique if you take a look here at the
region that we're in it doesn't actually
select a specific region it selects the
global option which means that this
bucket will become globally accessible
so that is why it needs to have a unique
name much like a DNS name has to be
unique for your website right so I'm
going to come up here
and pick a name that I think is going to
be unique so I'm going to say simply
learn
S3 demo
all right let's take a look at if that's
going to work out of course we have to
pick a region but it is globally
accessible so you either pick a region
that's closest to your end users or in
our case since we're just doing a
demonstration we can do whichever is
closer to us right now okay and we're
going to skip these options for now
we're going to come back to them later
on we're just going to create
the bucket
now hopefully that was a unique name and
allowed me to create that and it looks
like it did so if I scroll down you can
see that it clearly got created over
here
now we're going to click on that and
we're going to start
uploading objects to this bucket
so let me click on the upload button and
you can either select one or more files
or you can select an entire folder so
I'm going to just go and select a
specific cat picture that I have here
okay and again we'll go through some of
those other options later on and we'll
just click upload
now this should take no time at all
because of the fact that's a very small
object or file that's being uploaded so
it is has succeeded we can close this up
and we see now clearly that the object
is in our bucket if we go to properties
we can see the metadata associated with
this bucket we can see the region that
it's in we can see the Arn which is the
Amazon resource name which uniquely
identifies this resource this bucket
across the globe so if ever you needed
to reference this let's say in an IM
policy or with other other service
needed to communicate with S3 you would
need this Arn it's a very important
piece of information and of course we
have the creation date some some high
level metadata so objects as we have
covered already consist of not only the
data itself but the metadata so there's
lots of metadata and there's a lot of
other features that we can go here and
enable very easily and this will be the
basis of the future demonstrations that
I'm going to do all right so just to
recap what we just did we created a
unique bucket
give it a name of
simply learn S3 demo and uploaded our
first object to it
so let's now take a look at the inner
workings of the Amazon S3
when we upload an object into a bucket
we have to select which one of these
storage classes the object will reside
in so you see have six storage classes
here at the bottom and each have their
own characteristics that we're going to
get
into by default
if you don't specify anything it'll get
placed in What's called the S3 standard
storage class which is the most
expensive out of all these storage
classes
once your object gets colder and what I
mean by colder is your axis patterns
diminish meaning that you're accessing
that file less and less over the course
of time so it gets colder
you will transition that object from one
tier to the next all the way to for
example S3 deep archive so again deep
archive signifies extremely cold so
maybe you're only referencing this data
once a year once every couple of years
and so you want to have the cheapest
possible storage available so right now
you can get about one terabyte of
storage per month for about a dollar a
month with S3 Glacier deep archive so
you are going to be very interested in
knowing how to transition from one or
more of these storage classes over time
in order to save on your storage costs
that's really why we're doing this so
let's go through some of these storage
classes by default like I said whenever
you upload an object you automatically
get placed into the standard storage
class so any files that you're working
on frequently daily this is the best fit
for it got the highest level
of accessibility and durability as well
not that the others don't have the same
level of durability however we'll see
how when you transition from one
storage tier to the next some
characteristics do change in order for
you to save on some cost we're going to
go through some of those now this would
be considered hot data right data that's
used all the time maybe just by you
maybe by everybody a month that document
was submitted shins based on feedback
from your colleagues that are asking you
to make some corrections or some
amendments and so only those Corrections
or amendments come in perhaps once a
month and so in that case you might find
yourself
finding a justification for moving that
document from the standard tier to the
standard IA or infrequently accessed
here maybe any objects not modified for
more than 30 days are a good fit for
that and that's really the criteria for
IA in active access is that S3
or AWS itself recommends to only put
objects in there if they haven't been
asked to access for at least 30 days so
you get a a price reduction a rebate for
putting objects that are not accessed
frequently in here of course if you
remove objects let's say before the
30-day limit then you are charged a
surcharge for retrieving an object that
you said was infrequently accessed but
it really was not so bear that in mind
if you're going to place objects in in
frequent access
be somewhat reasonably assured that
you're not going to be going there and
accessing them you can still access
those files no problem just as quickly
they have the same level of
accessibility and durability however
like I said anything less than 30 days
you'll get a price ding on that
if you want to have long-term storage
we're talking about Amazon Glacier so
this is more anything over 90 days that
hasn't been modified or 180 days there's
two subcategories of Amazon Glacier that
we're going to get into and this is the
cheapest storage by far and Amazon
Glacier doesn't really operate through
the AWS console as the same as the
standard and the infrequent access you
can't really upload objects to Glacier
via the console in the browser
you can only do so let's say through the
command line interface or through an SDK
the only thing you can do on the web
console with Glacier is actually create
what's called a vault which is a logical
container for your archives but then
after that you have to go through the
CLI or the SDK to do the rest of the
work there
if we continue on there's some gray
areas between uh the S3 standard in a
glacier one is the one zone in
frequently accessed storage class so if
we go back to the regular standard and
IA storage class all of these objects
are stored across a minimum of three
availability zones
if you want a further price reduction
you can store your objects in a one zone
IA storage class which means that
instead of taking that object and
replicating it across three or more
availability zones it will only start in
a single availability Zone therefore
reducing
at the level of availability that you
have to that object so in this case here
if that single availability Zone would
go down for example you would not have
access to that object once it would come
back up of course you would the other
thing is is if there was a an immense
catastrophe where the actual
availability Zone was destroyed well of
course then your object is also gone so
if that's something that doesn't worry
you because you have already many copies
of this object maybe lying around on
premise then this is a good option for
you because it's data that you're
willing to lose or lose access to for
short periods of time if ever that
single availability Zone goes down so
it's about an extra 20 off the price
from already the normal IA standard
price
there is another one called the standard
reduced redundancy storage
this one is kind of getting phased out
as we speak because the same price for
this storage class is about the same
amount you're going to pay for the
normal IA standard class what this does
is again is a good fit for
um your objects that you're not really
worried about losing if there is some
sort of catastrophe that happens in an
availability Zone there's less copies of
it that are stored and so if that data
center and that availability Zone goes
down then you lose your object so of
course it offered at the time the
highest price reduction possible but now
the difference between this one and the
normal IA standard storage class is so
small in terms of price that you're
probably not going to migrate to or
navigate to this storage class but it is
still there in the documentation and it
may very well come up still in the
certification exam so at least be aware
of that
let's now take a look at some individual
features of S3 starting off with life
cycle management so life cycle
management is very interesting because
it allows us to come up with a
predefined rule that will help us
automate the transitioning of objects
from one storage class to another
without us having to manually copy
things over of course you could imagine
how time consuming that would be if we
had to do this manually
so we're going to see this very soon in
a lab however let me discuss how how
this works
so once we it's basically a graphical
user interface it's very very simple to
use once you come up with the position
action and the expiration action so the
transition action is going to be
something like well I want to transition
an object
from maybe it's all objects or maybe
it's just a specific type of from one
storage class let's say standard to
standard inactive or infrequent access
maybe only after 45 days after at least
a minimum of 30 days like we spoke of
before and then maybe after
90 days you want to transition the
objects in IA to right away Glacier deep
archive or 180 days you come up with
whatever combination you see fit okay it
doesn't have to be sequential for ms3 to
IA to one zone etc etc because like we
discussed before it depends what kind of
objects that you're interested in
putting in one zone objects that you
don't really mind losing if that one
availability Zone goes down so you're
going to be deciding those rules
it ends up that this even is not a
simple task because you have to monitor
your usage patterns to see which data is
hot which data is cold and what's the
best kind of life cycle management to
implement to reap the benefits of the
lowest cost so you have to put somebody
on this job and make the best informed
decisions based on your access patterns
and that is something that you need to
consistently monitor
so what we can do is we can instead opt
for something called S3 intelligent
tiering
which basically analyzes your workload
using machine learning algorithms
and after about a good 30 days of
analyzing your access patterns
will automatically be able to transition
your objects from S3 standard to S3
standard infrequent access okay it
doesn't go past the Ia one it doesn't go
after the glacier and whatnot okay so it
can then offer you
um that at a reduced price overhead so
there is a monitoring fee that is
introduced in order to implement this
feature it's a very nominal very very
low monitoring fee
and the nice thing is is if ever you
take out an object out of the infrequent
axis before the 30-day limit as we spoke
of before you will not be charged
um an overhead charge because of that
why because you're using the
intelligence tearing you're already
paying an overhead for the monitoring
fee so at least in that sense the
intelligent tearing will take the object
out of IA and put it back into the S3
standard class if you need access to it
before the 30 days and in that case you
will be charged that overhead so that is
something that is very
um that is very um good to to to do in
order not to have to put somebody on
that job so yes you're paying a little
bit of overhead for that monitoring fee
but at the other side of the spectrum
you're not investing in somebody uh
working many hours to Monitor and put
into place a system to monitor your data
access patterns so let's take a look at
how to do this right now let's Implement
our own
life cycle management rules
so let's now create a lifecycle rule
inside our bucket first off we're going
to need to go to the management tab
and the bucket that we just created and
right on the top you see right away life
cycle rule we're going to create
lifecycle Rule and we're going to name
it so I'm just going to say something
very simple like simply
learn
lifecycle rule
and we have the option of creating this
rule for every single object in the
bucket or we can limit the scope to a
certain type of file perhaps with a
prefix like
I could see one right now something like
logs so anything that we categorize as a
log file will transition from one
storage tier to the next as per our
instructions we're doing this because we
really want to save on costs right it's
not so much of organizing what's your
older data versus your newer data it's
more about
reducing that storage cost as your
objects get less and less used so in
this case the logs are a good fit
because perhaps you're using your logs
for the first 30 days you're sifting
through them you're trying to get
insights on them but then you kind of
move them out of the way because they
become old data and you don't need them
anymore so we're going to see how we can
transition them to another pricing to
another storage tier
uh we could also do this with object
tags which is a very powerful feature
and in the lifecycle rules action you
have to at least pick one of these
options now since we haven't enabled
versioning yet what I'm going to do is
just select transition to current
version of the object between these
storage classes
so as a reminder of what we already
covered in the slides are storage
classes are right over here so the one
that's missing is obviously
the default standard storage class which
all objects are placed in by default so
what we're going to say is this we want
our objects that are in the default
standard storage class to go to the
standard inactive access storage class
after 30 days and that'll give us a nice
discount on those objects being stored
then we want to add another transition
and let's say we want to transition them
to Glacier after 90 days
and then as a big finale we want to go
to Glacier deep archive you can see the
rest are grayed out would it make sense
to go back and maybe after 180 days we
want to go there okay now there's a
little bit of um a warning or a call to
attention here they're saying if you're
going to store very small files into
Glacier not a great idea there's an
overhead in terms of metadata that's
added and also there's an additional
cost associated with storing small files
in Glacier so we're just going to
acknowledge that of course for the
demonstration that's fine in real life
you'd want to store a very big tar files
or zip files that had you know one or
more log files in there okay that would
bypass that that surcharge that you
would get
and over here you have the timeline
summary of everything we selected up
above so we have here after 30 days
the standard inactive access after 90
days Glacier and after 180 days Glacier
deep archive so let's go and create that
rule
all right so we see that the rule is
already enabled and at any time you
could go back and disable this if ever
you had a reason to do so we can easily
delete it as well or view the details
and and edit as well so if we go back to
our bucket
now what I've done
is created that prefix with the slash
logs since we're not doing this from the
command line we're going to create a
logs folder over here that will fit that
prefix so I'm going to create logs
create folder
and now we're going to upload our let's
say our Apache log files in here so
we're going to upload one demonstration
Apache log file that I've created with
just one line in there of course just
for demonstration purposes we're going
to upload that
and now we have we're going to close
that and now we have our our Apache log
file in there so what's going to happen
because we have that life cycle rule in
place after 30 days anything any file
that has the logs prefix where basically
is placed inside this folder will be
transitioned as per that life cycle row
policy that we just created so
congratulations you just created your
first S3 lifecycle rule policy
let's now move over to bucket policies
so bucket policies are going to allow or
deny access to not only the bucket
itself but the objects within those
buckets to either specific users or
other services that are inside the AWS
Network now these policies fall under
the category of I am policy so IM stands
for identity and access management and
this is a whole other topic that deals
with security at large so there are no
services in AWS which are allowed to
access other services or data for
example within S3 without you explicitly
allowing it through these IM policies so
one of the ways we do that is by
attaching one of these policies which
are written in a Json on format so it's
a text file that we write at the end of
the day that's the artifact and that's a
good thing because we can use that
artifact
and we can configuration control it in
our source control and version it and
put it alongside our source code
so when we deploy everything it is part
of our deployment package so in this
case here we have several ways of doing
this we can use What's called the policy
generator which is a graphical user
interface that allows us to Simply click
and point and populate certain text
boxes which will then generate that Json
document that will allow us to attach
that to our S3 bucket and that will
determine like I said which users or
Services have access to
whatever API actions are available for
that resource so we might say we want
certain users to be able just to list
the contents of this bucket not
necessarily be able to delete or upload
new objects into that bucket so you can
get very fine-grained permissions based
on the kind of actions you want to allow
on this resource so in order to really
we bring this home let's go and perform
our very own lab on this
let's now see how to create an S3 bucket
policy going back to our bucket we're
now going to go into permissions
so the whole point of coming up with a
bucket policy is that we want to control
who or what the what being other
services have access to our bucket and
our objects within our bucket so there
are several ways we can go about doing
this let's edit a bucket policy
one we can go and look at a whole bunch
of pre-canned examples which is a good
thing to do
two we could actually go in here and
code the Json document ourselves which
is much more difficult of course so what
we're going to do is we're going to look
at a policy generator which is really a
form-based graphical user interface that
allows us to generate through the
answers that we're going to give here
the Json document for us
first question is we got to select the
policy type of course we're dealing with
S3 so it makes sense for us to create an
S3 bucket policy
the two options available to us are
allowing or denying
access to
RS3 bucket now in this case here we
could get really
fine-grained and specify certain kinds
of services or certain kinds of users
but for the demonstration we're just
going to select star which means
anything or anybody can access this S3
bucket all right now depending on also
the actions that we're going to allow so
in this case here we can get very fine
grained and we have all these check
boxes that we can check off to give
access to certain kind of API action so
we can say we want to give access to you
know just deleting the bucket which
obviously is something very powerful but
you can get more fine-grained as you can
see you have more of the Getters over
here and you have more of the
the the listing and the putting new
objects in there as well so you can get
very fine grain now for demonstration
purposes we're going to say all actions
so this is a very
Broad and wide ranging permission
something that you really should think
twice about before doing where it's
basically saying we want to allow
everybody and anything any service all
API actions on this S3 bucket so that's
no a small thing
we need to specify the Amazon resource
name the Arn of that bucket specifically
so what we're going to do is go back to
our bucket
and you can see here uh the bucket Arn
okay so we're just going to copy this
paste it in this policy generator and
just say add statement you can see here
kind of a resume of what we just did and
we're going to say generate policy and
this is where it creates for us and make
this a little bit bigger for us it
creates that Json document so we're
going to take this we're going to copy
it and we're going to paste it into
the generator okay now of course we
could flip this and change this to a
deny
right which would basically say we don't
want anybody to have access or any thing
any other service to have access to this
S3 bucket we could even say
slash star to also encapsulate all the
objects within that bucket so if I save
this right now
you have a very iron-clad
S3 bucket policy which basically denies
All Access
to this bucket and the objects within of
course this is on the other side of the
spectrum very very secure so we might
want to for example host a static
website
through our S3 bucket so in this case
here allowing access would make more
sense right so if I save changes you see
that we get an error here saying that we
don't have permissions to do this
and the reason for that is because it
realizes that this is extremely
permissive so in order to give access to
every single object within this bucket
as in the case that I was stating of a
static website being hosted on your S3
bucket it would be much better to also
it first enable that option so I'm just
going to duplicate the tab here
and once you go back to the permissions
tab one of the first things that shows
up is this block Public Access setting
right right now it's completely blocked
and that's what's stopping us from
saving our policy we would have to go in
here
unblock it and save it right and it's
also kind of like a double clutch
feature you have to confirm that just so
you don't do that by accident
right so now what you've effectively
done is you've really opened up the
floodgates to have public access to this
bucket it's something that can't be
accidentally done it's kind of like
having to perform these two actions
before the public access can be granted
now historically this was something that
AWS was
um
was guilty of was making it too easy to
have Public Access so now we have this
double clutch now that this is enabled
or turned off we can now save
our changes here successfully
and you can see here that now it's
publicly accessible which is a big red
flag that perhaps this is not something
that you're interested in doing now if
you're hosting a public website and you
want everybody just to have read access
to every single object in your bucket
yes this is fine however please make
sure that you
um
pay very close attention to this type of
access flagged over here on the console
so congratulations you just got
introduced to your first bucket policy a
permissive one but at least now you know
how to go through that graphical user
interface through the policy generator
and create them and paste them inside
your S3 bucket policy pane
so let's continue on with data
encryption so any data that you place in
S3 bucket can be encrypted at rest very
easily
using an AES 256 encryption key so we
can have server side encryption we could
have AWS handle all the encryption for
us and the decryption will also be
handled by AWS when we request our
objects later on but we could also have
client-side encryption where we the
client that are uploading the object
have to be responsible for also passing
over our own generated key that will
eventually be used by AWS to then
encrypt that object on the bucket side
of course once that happens then the key
is discarded the client key is discarded
and you have to be very mindful that
since you've decided to handle your own
encryption client-side encryption that
if ever you lose those keys well that
data is not going to be recoverable in
that bucket on the AWS Network so be
very careful on that point
we can also have a very useful feature
called versioning which will allow you
to have a history of all the changes of
an object over time so versioning sounds
exactly how it's named every time you
make a modification to a file and upload
that new version to S3 it will have a
brand new version ID associated with
that so over time you get a sort of
stack of a history of all the file
changes over time so you can see here at
the bottom you have an ID with all these
ones and then an ID with one two one two
one two So eventually if ever you wanted
to revert back to a previous version you
could do so by accessing one of those
previous versions of course versioning
is not an option that's enabled by
default you have to go ahead and enable
that yourself it is extremely simple
thing to do
and so there may be a situation where
you already have objects within your
buckets and you only then enable
versioning well versioning would only
apply to the new objects that would get
uploaded from the point that you enabled
versioning the objects that were there
before that point will not get a
specific version number attached in fact
they will have a sort of null marker the
version number that will get attached to
them it's only after that you modify
those objects later on and upload a new
version that they will get their own
version numbers
so right now what we're going to be
doing is a lab on actual versioning so
let's go ahead and do that right now
in this lab we're going to see how to
enable versioning in our buckets enabled
versioning is very easy we're simply
going to click on our bucket go into
properties and there is going to be a
bucket versioning section
I'm going to click on edit and enable it
once that's done
any new objects
that are uploaded to that S3 bucket will
now benefit from being tracked by a
version number so if you upload
objects with the same file name after
that they'll each have a different
version number so you'll have version
tracking a history of the changes for
that object let's actually go there and
upload a new file
I'll upload one called index.html so
we're going to simulate a situation
where we've decided we're going to use
an S3 bucket as the source of our static
website to deploy one and in this
index.html file if you take a look right
now let's take a look at what's in there
you can see that we have welcome to my
website and we're at version two okay so
if I click on this file right now
and I go to versions
I can clearly see that there's some
version activity that's happening here
okay we have here
at 1456 which is the latest one the
latest one is on the top the current
version we have the specific version ID
and then we have a sort of history of
what's going on here
now I purposely enabled versioning
before and then tried to
delete version or disable versioning but
here's the thing with versioning you
cannot disable it fully once it's
enabled you can only suspend it
right now suspending means that whatever
version numbers those objects had before
you decided to suspend it will remain so
you can see I have an older version here
that has an older version number and at
this point here I decided to suspend
versioning and so what it does instead
of disabling the entire history it puts
what's called a delete marker okay you
could always roll back to that version
if you want now in the demonstration
when we started it together I enabled it
again so you can see this is actually
the brand new version number as we did
it together but you don't lose the
history of previous versioning if ever
you had suspended it before so that's
something to keep in mind right and
it'll come up in the exam where they'll
ask you can you actually disable
versioning once it's enabled and the
answer is no you can only suspend it and
your history is still maintained now we
have that version there and let's say I
come to this file and I want to upgrade
this I don't know I say version three
right and now it's going to happen
is if I click on this version this is
the current one with version two and I
open this we should see version two
which is fine that's that's that's
expected if we go back to our bucket and
upload that new version file that has
version three in there
they want to just modify it
we should now see in that index.html
file a brand new version that was
created
under the versions Tab and there you go
1458 just two minutes after you can see
here we have a brand new version ID
right and if I open this one
you can see version three so now you
have a way to enable versioning very
easily in your buckets and you also have
seen what happens when you want to
suspend versioning what happens to the
history of those versions files before
just to actually go back here to the
properties
uh where we enabled version in the first
place if I want to go back in here and
disable it like I said you can't disable
you can only suspend and that's where
that delete marker gets placed but all
your previous versions retain their
version ID so don't forget that because
that will definitely be a question on
your exam if you're interested in taking
the certification exam so
congratulations you just learned how to
enable
versioning
let's move on
to cross region replication or crr as it
is known there will be many times when
you find yourself with objects in a
bucket and you want to share those
objects with another bucket now that
other bucket could be within the same
account could be within another account
within the same region or could be
within a separate account in a different
region so there's varying levels of
degree there the good thing is is all of
those
um combinations are available so crr if
we're talking about cross region
replication is really about replicating
objects across regions something that is
not enabled by default because that will
incur a replication charge because it's
syncing objects across regions of course
you are spanning a very wide area
network in that case so there is a
surcharge for that
now doing so is quite simple to do but
one of the things that we have to be
mindful of is to give permissions for
the source bucket which has the
originals
to allow for this copying of objects to
the destination bucket so if we're doing
this across regions of course we would
have to come up with IM policies and we
would also have to exchange credentials
in terms of
IM user credentials in terms of account
IDs and the such we're going to be doing
a demonstration in the same account in
the same region but largely this would
be the same steps if we were going to go
cross region so this is something you
might find yourself doing if you want to
share data with other
um entities in your company maybe you're
a multinational and you want to have all
your lock files copied over to another
bucket in another region for another
team to analyze to extract business
insights from or it might just be that
you want to aggregate data in a separate
data Lake in an S3 bucket in another
region or in a like I said it could be
even in the same region or in the same
account so it's all about organizing
moving data around across objects across
these boundaries and let's actually go
through a demonstration and see how we
can do crr
let's now see how we can perform cross
region replication
we're going to take all the new objects
that are going to be uploaded in the
simply learn S3 demo bucket and we're
going to replicate them into a
destination bucket so what we're first
going to do is create a new bucket okay
and we'll just tack on the number two
here and this will be our destination
bucket where all those objects will be
replicated to we're going to demonstrate
this within the same account but it's
the exact same steps when doing this
across regions
one of the requirements when performing
cross-region replication is to enable
versioning so if you don't do this you
can do it at a later time but it is
necessary to enable it at some point in
time before coming up with a cross
region replication rule
all right so let me create that bucket
and now after the bucket is created I
want to go to the source bucket and I
want to configure under the managements
tab here
a replication rule
so I'm going to create a replication
rule call it
simply learn
rep rule
and I'm going to enable this right off
the bat
The Source bucket of course is the
simply learn S3 demo we could apply this
to all objects in the bucket or perform
a filter once again let's keep it simple
this time and apply to all objects in
the bucket of course caveat here this
will only now apply to any new objects
that are uploaded into this Source
bucket and not the ones that are already
pre-existing there okay now in terms of
the a destination bucket we want to
select the one we just created so we can
choose a bucket in this account or if we
really want to go across region or
another account in another region we
could specify this and put in the
account ID in the bucket name in that
other account
so we're going to stay in the same
account we're going to browse and select
the newly created bucket
and we're also going to need permissions
for the source bucket to dump those
objects into the destination bucket so
we can either create the role ahead of
time or we can ask this user interface
to create a new role for us so we'll opt
for that
and we'll skip these additional
features over here that we're not going
to talk about in this demonstration
we're just going to save this so that
will create our replication rule that is
automatically enabled for us right now
so let's take a look at the overview
here you can see it's been enabled just
to double check the destination bucket
is the demo two we're talking about the
same region
and again here we could opt for
additional
um parameters like different storage
classes in the destination bucket that
that object is going to be deposited in
etc etc for now we just created a simple
rule now if we go back to
the original Source bucket which we're
in right now and we upload a new file
which will be transactions file in a CSV
format
once this is uploaded
that cross region replication rule
will kick in and will eventually right
it's not immediate but will eventually
copy
the file inside the demo 2 bucket now I
know it's not there already so what I'm
going to do is pause the video and come
back in two minutes and when I click on
this the file should be in there
okay so let's now double check and make
sure that object has been replicated
and there it is been replicated as per
our rule so congratulations you just
learned how to perform your first same
account S3 bucket region replication
rule
I'll take a look at transfer
acceleration
so transfer acceleration is all about
giving your end users the best possible
experience when they're accessing
information in your bucket so you want
to give them the lowest latency possible
you can imagine if you were serving a
website
uh and you wanted people to have the
lowest latency possible of course that's
something that's very desirable so in
terms of traversing long distances if
you have your bucket that is in for
example the U.S east wine region in the
United States in the Virginia region and
you had users let's say in London that
want to access those objects of course
they would have to Traverse a longer
distance than users that were based in
in the United States and so if you
wanted to bring those objects closer to
them in terms of latency then we could
take advantage of What's called the
Amazon Cloud front delivery Network the
CDN Network which extends the AWS
backbone by providing what's called
Edge locations so Edge locations are
really data centers that are placed in
major city centers where our end users
mostly are located more densely
populated areas and your objects will be
cached in those locations so if we go
back to the example of your end users
being in London well they would be
accessing a cached copy of those objects
that were stored in the original bucket
in the for example Us East one region of
course you will get most likely a
dramatic performance increase by
enabling transfer accelerations very
simple to enable this just bear in mind
that when you do so that you will incur
a charge for using this feature the best
thing to do is to how to go ahead and do
this so let's do that right now
let's now take a look at how to enable
transfer acceleration on our
simply learn S3 demo bucket
by simply going to the properties tab we
can scroll down and look for a heading
called transfer acceleration
over here
and very simply just enable it
so what does this do
this allows us to take advantage of
What's called the contents delivery
Network the CDN which extends the AWS
Network backbone
the CDN network is strategically placed
into more densely populated areas for
example major city centers and so if
your end users
are situated in these more densely
populated areas they will reap the
benefits of having transfer acceleration
enabled because the latency that they
will experience will be severely
decreased so their performance is going
to be enhanced if we take a look at the
speed comparison page for transfer
acceleration we can see that once the
page is finished loading it's going to
do a comparison it's going to perform
first of all what's called a multi-part
upload and it's going to see how fast
that upload was done with or without
transfer acceleration enabled now this
is relative to where I am running this
test so right now I'm actually running
it from Europe so you can see that I'm
getting very very good results if I
would enable transfer acceleration and
my users were based in Virginia so of
course now I have varying
uh differences in percentage as I go
closer or further away from my region
where my bucket or my browser is being
um is being referenced so you can see
here United States I'm getting pretty
good uh percentages as I go closer to
Europe it gets lower of course but still
very very good Frankfurt again this is
about us probably at the worst I'm going
to be getting here since I'm situated in
Europe
and of course as I go look more towards
you know the Asian regions you can see
once again it kind of scales up in terms
of better performance so of course this
is an optional feature once you enable
it as I just showed over here this is a
feature that you pay additionally for
so bear that in mind make sure that you
take a look at the pricing page in order
to figure out how much this is going to
cost you so that is it congratulations
you just learned how to
simply enable transfer acceleration to
lower the latency from the end user's
point of view
foreign
things up in our conclusion and go over
at a very high level what we just spoke
about so we talked about what S3 is
which is a core service one of the
original Services published by AWS in
order for us to have unlimited object
storage in a secure scalable and durable
fashion we took a look at other aspects
of S3 in terms of the benefits we mainly
focused on the cost savings that we can
attain
in S3 by looking at different storage
classes now of course S3 is industry
recognized as one is the cheapest object
storage
Services out there that has the most
features available we saw what goes into
the object storage in terms of creating
first our buckets which are our
containers high level containers in
order for us to store our objects in
again objects are really an abstraction
of the type of data that are in there as
well as the metadata associated with
those objects
we took a look at the different storage
tiers the default being this standard
all the way till the cheapest one which
is the glacier which are meant for a
long term archived objects for example
log files that you may hold on to for a
couple of years may not need to access
routinely and we'll have the cheapest
pricing option by far so we have many
pricing tiers and if you want to
transition from one tier to the next you
would Implement a life cycle policy or
use the intelligent tiering option that
can do much of this for you we took a
look at some very interesting features
starting from the life cycle management
policies that we just talked about all
the way till versioning cross region
replication and transfer acceleration so
with this conclusion you are now ready
to at least start working with S3 hello
everybody my name is Kent and today
we're going to be covering AWS
identity and access management also
known as IM tutorial by simply learn
so these are the topics which we'll be
covering today we'll be defining what
AWS security is the different types of
security in AWS what exactly is identity
and access management
the benefits of identity and access
management
how I am works
its components its features and at the
end we're going to do a great demo on IM
with multi-factor authentication and
users and groups
so without any further Ado let's get
started
so let's get started with what is AWS
security
your organization May span many regions
or many accounts and you may Encompass
hundreds if not thousands of different
types of resources that need to be
secured and therefore you're going to
need a way to secure all that sensitive
data in a consistent way across all
those accounts in your organization
while meeting any compliancy and
confidentiality standards that have to
be met so for example if you're dealing
with Healthcare data or credit card
information or personal identification
information like addresses this is
something that needs to be thought out
across your organization so of course we
have Individual Services in AWS which we
will explore
in this video however in order to govern
the whole process at an organizational
level we have AWS security Hub now AWS
security Hub is known as a cspm which
stands for a cloud security posture
management tool so what does that really
mean well it's going to Encompass like I
said all these tools underneath the hood
in order to bring a streamlined way for
you to organize and adhere to these
standards across organization it'll
identify any misconfiguration issues and
compliant risks by continuously
monitoring your Cloud infrastructure for
the gaps in your security policy
enforcements now why is that important
well these misconfigurations
can lead to unwanted data breaches and
also data leakages so in order to govern
this at a very high level like I said we
need to incorporate AWS security Hub
that will automate and manage all these
underlying services for us in order to
perhaps take automated action we call
that remediary actions and you can
approve these actions
manually or you can automate those
actions as you see fit across your
organization so let's delve a little bit
deeper into what is AWS security and
then we'll start looking individually at
some of these services
and so our organization has special
needs across different projects and
environments so of course the production
development test environments all are
going to have their own unique needs
however it doesn't matter which project
or Which business unit we're talking
about and what are their storage backups
needs they should all be implemented in
a concise standardized way across your
organization to meet that compliancy
we're just talking about so we want to
automate all these tedious manual tasks
that we've been doing like ensuring that
perhaps our buckets in S3 are all
encrypted or all our EBS volumes are
encrypted and we want to have an
automated process in place in order to
give us time on other aspects of our
business perhaps our application
development to bring better business
value and that allows us to grow and
innovate the company and in a way that's
best suited for it so let's take a look
at the different types of AWS security
now there are many different types of
Security Services out there however
we're going to concentrate primarily on
IM in this video tutorial so I like to
think of I am as the glue between all
AWS Services because by default we don't
have permission for any one service to
communicate with another so let's just
take for example an ec2 instance that
wants to retrieve an object from S3
while those two Services could not
interact unless we interacted with I am
so something that's extremely important
to learn and by the end of this video
tutorial you'll be able to understand
what im is
we have Amazon guard Duty here which is
all about logs basically Aggregates all
logs from example cloudtrail which we
still haven't talked about at the end of
this list over here but instead of
looking at cloudtrail individually guard
Duty will actually take a look at Trail
cloudtrail will take a look at your VPC
flow logs and we'll take a look at your
DNS logs and monitor that account and
your network and your data access via
machine learning algorithms and it'll ID
any threat
where you can automatically remediate
the workflow that you've approved so for
example if you know of a malicious IP
address that's making API calls well
those API calls are registered